[Music]
annie joins us up next in topeka kansas
annie welcome to the show
hi um i was just wondering if with my
refund check from the government for
student loans if i should use it toward
my mortgage or if i should use it to be
generous or help somebody out
that's a very sweet question now annie
this is all
conjecture right this is theoretical if
and when you get the refund yeah okay i
was like did you already get the refund
am i hearing things okay i did talk to
my loan provider and they're like okay
we issued the refund you should see it
in your account wow
this is big news
yeah it's like whoa
so you guys are in baby steps four five
and six
yes okay how much is left on the
mortgage
um
two
a lot we just bought the house okay
cool cool cool and you're wondering
should i be generous with what do i do
with the money when i get it is your
question right okay
well i would apply it to the baby steps
and if you want to give a portion of
that i think it's a great thing to do if
that's what your your hearts are driving
you towards uh but definitely apply it
to that mortgage do you know if it's
going to be a certain amount is it 10
yes okay cool rachel what are your
thoughts my husband is going to apply as
well so and he's got he would get
another 10 there
yes
cool yeah that's great i mean i would
just keep throwing it i would yeah you
definitely can give some for sure i mean
obviously there's never
a negative when you're when you're
giving uh and so using that using the
remainder though to continue
to whether you guys are saving up um to
replace a car if that's in the if that's
in the equation if there's any big
purchase coming up you can obviously use
it for that or yeah just throw it there
at the mortgage at baby step six uh
would be very smart that'll feel good to
see that balance go down